*Bruit de carton qui tombe*
*Voix de Squeezie* Ahhh... Putaaain...
*Bruit de vaisselle cassée*
*Voix de Squeezie* Où il est, à la fin... ?
Ahhh, je l'ai !
Je parle du thread d'aujourd'hui...
Aujourd'hui, j'ai compris, ça vous plaît un peu moins les threads autour des chaînes YouTube étranges,
parce que c'est tout de suite grillé que c'est du fake.
Alors que les threads Twitter, on sait pas trop !
Aujourd'hui, on va parler d'un thread espagnol,
que Lauren (Luciole) (la tête ici de Luciole)
a traduit pour nous.
Et maintenant je compte jusqu'à trois et tous ensemble on dit : "merci Lauren".
Un, deux, trois :
*avec de l'écho* merci Lauren...
*Rire* J'suis insupportable...
Vous allez voir, il y a un peu de... de sortes d'énigmes à résoudre,
un p'tit peu comme le thread avec le message vocal, à l'époque.
Il y a un p'tit peu des trucs comme ça et du coup je pense que ça va vraiment vous plaire.
Moi, en tout cas, ça fait longtemps que j'avais pas kiffé devant un thread comme devant celui-là.
Alors on y va ! *Clappement de mains*
Tout commence le 20 août 2018, lorsque Nela Garcia dit avoir trouvé un téléphone.
Elle pensait d'abord qu'il appartenait à la fille qu'on voit sur la page d'accueil du téléphone,
mais en fait, non, cette fille... *cloche d'église*
est MORTE,
aux États-Unis, huit ans avant.
Alors qu'est-ce que son téléphone fait là ?
Ça commence si bien !
Elle nous précise qu'elle a trouvé ce téléphone en rentrant chez elle,
à Madrid, dans un parc.
Comme il n'y avait pas de mot de passe, Nela elle commence à fouiller dans le téléphone
pour trouver des numéros, des pistes en fait,
mais là, première douche froide : *cloche*
AUCUN contact enregistré dans le téléphone.
Comme s'il était neuf.
Mais il est pas neuf, puisqu'y a la photo de cette meuf, là, en page d'accueil !
C'est bizarre !
En fouillant, Nela, tout ce qu'elle trouve, c'est un compte Facebook et un compte Instagram,
mais c'est comme ça qu'elle est remontée jusqu'à la "potentielle" propriétaire du téléphone.
J'ai fait des "guillemets" comme un gros connard...
Facebook et Insta', sur lesquels y'a quelqu'un qui était logué, quelqu'un qui répondait au nom de...
non pas Bella, mais...
*accent espagnol* Marta Cutiérrez.
Le contenu de ce compte Insta' est un peu chelou, parce qu'il y a très très peu de photos d'elle,
c'est assez impersonnel, c'est surtout des photos de paysages et de bâtiments
avec aucune légende et aucun commentaire,
et en plus, elle suit personne et personne ne la suit non plus.
C'est vraiment chelou, comme compte Insta'.
Alors, qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire de plus quand on en est là ?
*Bruit de clin d’œil* Sans faire de jeu de mots, parce qu'elle s'appelle Nela...
AHHH !
J'ai pas fait exprès et j'suis fier de moi !
Pardon, j'ai pas de quoi être fier, j'devrais avoir honte. *Toux gênée*
On oublie les jeux de mots de merde.
Nela, elle va avoir vraiment une bonne idée :
elle va faire une recherche d'image Google à partir de la photo de profil Facebook de Marta.
Nela tombe alors sur un blog,
dont la photo de profil est la même photo de profil que le Facebook de Marta,
sauf que, chose très bizarre,
l'auteur du blog, c'est pas du tout Marta,
c'est Beatrice Williams.
Qu'est-ce que c'est qu'cette merde ?
Le blog date de 2008 et c'est que des photos d'une étudiante américaine en voyage en Espagne.
Et les photos sont exactement les mêmes que celles sur le Facebook de Marta.
On en vient donc à la conclusion que Marta...
n'existe pas,
et que c'est juste quelqu'un qui a créé ce compte et qui utilise toutes les photos du blog de Beatrice Williams.
Nela va trouver le mail de Beatrice dans la bio de son blog,
elle va lui envoyer un mail pour la prévenir que quelqu'un usurpe son identité
et vole toutes ses photos pour les mettre sur un faux compte Facebook,
qui répond au nom de Marta.
*Rire*
J'ai "Bella" dans la tête, ça influence toutes mes phrases.
C'est pas Beatrice qui a répondu à ce mail, mais c'est son père,
et son père apprend à Nela que Beatrice est morte il y a huit ans.
Il avait déjà vu et signalé quelques comptes qui usurpaient l'identité de sa fille
et demande à Nela de faire de même pour que ces comptes soient clôturés.
Ça veut donc dire que le téléphone que Nela a trouvé,
il appartient pas à Beatrice,
mais il appartient à Marta,
même si y'a une photo de Beatrice en fond d'écran.
Nela, elle veut donc retrouver cette fameuse Marta
et aussi p't-être comprendre pourquoi elle a usurpé l'identité de Béatrice,
c'est chelou quand même.
Nela va checker dans le journal des appels si elle a émis ou reçu des appels d'un numéro
et elle a uniquement émis des appels envers un numéro,
mais BEAUCOUP d'appels.
En toute logique, elle va donc appeler ce même numéro
pour essayer de retrouver la trace de Marta, la propriétaire du téléphone,
et elle va tomber sur un truc...
parfaitement chelou.
*Voix grave et robotique qui parle espagnol*
Ohhh, c'est quoi !
C'est "Saw" !
C'est "Saw" dans la vraie vie, en fait, c'est ça hein...
Autre truc bizarre,
Marta avait aussi reçu pleins de SMS de ce numéro,
qui étaient des séries de chiffres et de lettres incompréhensibles.
On pense donc que le tél' appartenait à un escroc qui jouait à un jeu,
un jeu p't-être un peu dangereux ou flippant
ou illégal,
et que pour pas se faire chopper par les autorités,
il a usurpé l'identité de Beatrice, qui est décédée,
comme ça, il risque rien si le téléphone est retrouvé
ou si les appels sont tracés ou quoi.
Ou alors, peut-être que c'était simplement à quelqu'un qui jouait à une sorte de jeu,
vous savez, comme ce jeu de merde, là, le blue whale challenge ou le momo challenge,
qui sont des trucs mais nul à chier, c'est horrible, ne faîtes jamais ça, c'est pourri !
C'est des sortes de jeux où en gros y'a quelqu'un qui va te dire "fait ci, fait ça, fait ci, fait ça",
puis ensuite il va te voler des données personnelles,
il va te mettre vraiment en danger, il va niquer ta santé mentale,
et ça finit même des fois par des suicides...
Alors voilà, p'tit message d'avertissement en passant dans ce thread :
ne jouez jamais à ces jeux,
c'est débile, futile, ça sert à rien
et les gens qui sont derrière ces jeux-là
sont démoniaques !
Ce téléphone appartenait donc sûrement à quelqu'un qui jouait à l'un de ces jeux malsains-là,
un nouveau jeu, peut-être.
Alors, est-ce que la personne à qui appartient le téléphone
a juste jeté le téléphone et arrêté de jouer parce qu'elle a pris peur ?
Ou alors, est-ce que cette personne s'est faite...
*bruit inquiétant* éliminer,
parce qu'elle a vu un truc qu'il faut pas, elle a fait un truc qu'il faut pas dans le jeu,
et ça a... dérapé ?
On sait pas !
Il nous reste donc comme éléments juste les séquences de lettres et de chiffres
que le téléphone avait reçu par messages
et y'en a au total douze.
Vous savez très bien à quoi ça correspond, on est habitué...
des coordonnées GPS, bien sûr !
Quelqu'un va alors placer chaque repère sur une map
et envoyer le screen à Nela,
et ça donne un truc... un peu abstrait, hein.
En tout cas, tous les points correspondent à des endroits à Madrid.
Nela va ensuite faire une découverte très intéressante,
elle remarque que chaque fin de série est constituée
d'une date, d'une heure
et d'une orientation.
Nela va alors prendre l'une de ces séquences et tester sa théorie
en mettant les coordonnées sur Google Street
et en orientant la caméra dans la direction indiquée,
en l’occurrence l'Est,
et BOUM *bruit d'explosion lointain*
on obtient une photo du même point de vue
qu'une photo qui se trouve sur le compte Instagram de Marta.
Coïncidence ?
Huuum... Nan !
Elle va tester avec tous les SMS,
et chaque SMS reçu correspond en fait à une photo de Insta'.
C'est lié !
C'est évident !
Les photos de ce compte Instagram sont des photos qui ne se trouvent PAS sur le blog de Beatrice William,
donc on suppose que c'est des photos qu'ont vraiment été prises par la personne qui avait ce téléphone.
L'enregistrement parlait de douze épreuves,
on en est à onze photos,
alors Nela, qu'est-ce qu'elle va faire ?
Elle va s'en charger !
La dernière photo doit donc être prise le 21 août
à 23h47,
aux coordonnées indiquées par le SMS.
Elle va taper les coordonnées sur Google Street et on tombe sur...
un parc,
y'a que des arbres, comme dans n'importe quel parc.
Mais alors pourquoi y'a une heure précise pour prendre ces photos, c'est chelou !
Elle va alors compter ce qu'il est possible de compter sur chaque photo qu'y'a sur le compte Instagram.
Par exemple, sur une photo y'a une main, on peut y compter cinq doigts ;
sur une autre photo y'a des tours et on peut en compter quatre.
Parfois sur des photos, y'a même directement marqué un chiffre,
par exemple sur celle-ci, où y'a marqué "81".
Bref, quand on applique ça à chaque photo ça nous donne pareil, une série de chiffres.
Qui sert sûrement à qu'que chose, pour débloquer une autre étape du jeu,
on va voir ça après.
Le soir-même, Nela doit s'occuper de sa mère qui habite loin de l'endroit indiqué,
alors elle va demander à des Twittos d'aller prendre la photo.
Putain, elle met en danger ses followers, quoi !
Faut pas la suivre, Nela, faut pas la suivre !
*Petit rire*
Elle reçoit donc pas mal de photos,
et le point commun dans toutes ces photos,
c'est qu'y'a un poteau sur lequel il y a marqué "361".
On a donc le dernier nombre qui complète cette série.
Elle envoie donc la série au numéro,
elle reçoit un SMS qui lui dit qu'"il est incorrect,
mais tu n'es pas loin.
On te laisse une dernière opportunité.
Réfléchis bien."
Le coup de pression.
En publiant la dernière photo sur Insta',
Nela s'aperçoit que... bah y'a certaines photos qui ont été prises de nuit et d'autres de jour du coup,
parce qu'y'avait une heure imposée par photo, comme on l'a dit,
et tout ça a été fait de manière à ce que les photos de nuit forment un "F".
Nela, elle pense que c'est pas une coïncidence
et elle veut ajouter le "F" au code ;
elle décide de le mettre à la fin du code et elle envoie ça au numéro en question,
et là, surprise...
*Musique inquiétante et bruit de singe*
Un petit singe rouge choqué.
Elle va donc rappeler le numéro
et le message n'est plus le même qu'avant :
*Voix grave et robotique qui parle espagnol*
A partir de là,
les énigmes s'enchaînent
et je vais vous les raconter un peu en accéléré parce que ça dure vraiment mille ans
et c'est ABUSÉ comme le jeu va loin...
Et c'est abusé comment c'est dur,
genre heureusement que Nela elle a pleins pleins de followers, sinon elle aurait JA-MAIS pu trouver...
BON ! Nela elle va donc analyser le code de l'image
et elle va tomber sur une URL.
En tapant l'URL dans son navigateur,
ça va l'amener sur un site chelou,
où y'a un compte à rebours qu'est en cours.
Est-ce que le compte à rebours s'est déclenché au moment où elle est arrivée sur le site
ou est-ce qu'il dure depuis que touuut le jeu a commencé,
on sait pas !
Et en dessous de ce compte à rebours, y'a une indication :
"entrer la réponse ici".
Quelle réponse ?!
On tape quoi, bordel ?
Elle est passée d'une épreuve à une autre, alors elle va rappeler le numéro
et elle a bien fait, parce que le numéro maintenant dit autre chose :
*Voix grave et robotique qui parle espagnol*
"La première phrase du premier livre"...
Ok...
Parallèlement, elle s'est fait hacké son compte Facebook,
et son image de profil et sa bannière ont été remplacées par des images de singes rouges.
On suppose donc que les mecs qu'y'a derrière le jeu sont des putains de hackers.
"La première phrase du premier livre",
il s'agit en fait de la première phrase du livre "La Genèse"
qui est la suivante :
"Le premier jour, Dieu créa le ciel et la terre".
Elle va alors taper ça sur le site
et apparemment c'était le bon truc à marquer parce qu'elle va recevoir un mail,
dans lequel y'a marqué un code binaire.
*Bruit d’essoufflement* C'est quoi ces énigmes ?
Ça n'arrête plus !
Et l'objet du mail est un peu creepy, parce qu'il dit :
"assure-toi d'avoir ta webcam allumée pendant que tu lis ce mail".
Est-ce que t'as accès à ma webcam, connard de hacker ? *Petit rire*
La webcam de Nela se met alors à clignoter.
C'est un peu flippant, elle dit qu'elle redémarre son Mac et que ça continue à clignoter.
Et des Twittos vont dire à Nela que le code binaire qu'y'a dans le mail, quand on le traduit,
ça donne un lien Vimeo.
Petit problème, la vidéo Vimeo elle est en privé
et il faut un code pour pouvoir la voir.
Oui, on peut faire ça sur Vimeo.
Les gens vont donc très vite comprendre que les clignotements de la webcam de Nela,
c'est un second code Morse,
qui, lorsqu'on le traduit, nous donne le code qui permet d'accéder à la vidéo Vimeo.
Ça va loin bordel, moi mon cerveau, là, il pète !
Moi, le téléphone j'le refous dans le parc, j'm'en bats les couilles...
En tout cas, sa théorie était bonne, puisqu'elle a pu accéder à la vidéo Vimeo
et... elle aurait préféré ne pas y accéder du tout, d'ailleurs.
*Musique inquiétante*
Ohhh, mais c'est creepy,
en fait, ce jeu il est pas du tout sain, en fait...
Un mec, avec un masque de singe,
s'est introduit
chez Nela et sa mère.
C'est clairement le pire truc qui peut t'arriver hein,
trouver une vidéo où c'est un mec qu'est chez toi, qui te filme pendant que tu dors
et t'as jamais su que c'était arrivé et tu le découvres
et tu te sens très très mal.
A la fin de la vidéo, on voit très clairement le mec
retirer la coque du téléphone de Nela
et y glisser un p'tit papier.
Donc Nela, elle va récupérer ce p'tit papier, elle va le tweeter,
et il dit un truc pas très... cool,
puisqu'il dit :
"Nous la tenons. Nous la ramènerons ici en fonction de toi.
Viens seule. Ne dis pas où et quand."
Et à la suite de cette phrase, y'a marqué une adresse.
Alors là, on commence à toucher à la fin.
Ça part en kidnapping, donc c'est chelou !
Réaction humaine : plutôt que d'aller voir la police et de leur dire c'qu'il se passe,
t'as peur que ça mette en péril euh... ton proche,
donc tu fais ce que les méchants ils disent, voilà,
tu vas au rendez-vous.
C'est ce que Nela elle va faire.
Et elle va, en arrivant sur place, prendre des vidéos de ce qu'elle voit,
parce que c'est très chelou.
*Bruit de pas lents*
*Respiration haletante et angoissée*
*Musique angoissante*
*Souffle coupé par la surprise*
*Respiration s'accélère*
*Musique angoissante s'intensifie*
*Coffre qui se ferme*
Baaah ouiii ! Quelle bonne idée !
Bah entre dans le coffre, Nela, vas-y, j't'en prie !
Ça m'énerve, là, quand les gens 'y sont stupides, là...
C'est comme dans les films, ça m'énerve !
Elle va tweeter que la voiture a fait un arrêt et qu'y'a quelqu'un d'autre qu'est monté dedans,
mais elle sait pas qui, quand, comment, ni où ils vont.
Les kidnappeurs de Nela vont alors la laisser dans un garage
et se barrer,
et elle tweete une photo, elle nous dit
bah voilà, j'sais pas où j'suis, ils m'ont laissé là, y'a personne, j'sais pas quoi foutre.
Elle va errer dans ce parking moisi complètement vide
et elle va trouver un ascenseur,
et dans cet ascenseur, y'a juste
un seul bouton.
Pendant que l'ascenceur monte, sur l'écran,
on voit le logo du singe rouge qui apparaît.
Elle est peut-être au cœur du gang qui gère tout ça depuis le début.
Les portes de l'ascenseur s'ouvrent, Nela descend
et elle filme tout de suite ce qu'elle voit
et c'est putain de creepy, c'est genre vraiment un décor de film d'horreur.
T'as vraiment pas envie d'être là de toute ta vie.
Et là, elle tombe sur un ordinateur.
*Bruit de singe*
"Écoute le son de la jungle"
avec un code à taper.
Elle teste "singe", "singe rouge", y'a rien qui marche,
et y'a un Tweetos qui lui sauve la vie.
Il a shazame la bande son de la vidéo
et, apparemment, c'est un titre interprété par
"Red Monkeys Deux"
*Clappement de main* Bingo !
C'est le bon code !
Est-ce qu'on arrive enfin à la fin
et on va savoir pourquoi, c'est quoi ce jeu et qui sont ces gens ?
Un dossier qui porte le nom de Nela...
Pas une énigme.
Pitié, y'a pas d'énigme, dedans.
Nela tweete que, d'après ce qu'elle vient de voir,
la fausse Marta et le portable
c'étaient juste des appâts dans le but d'attirer Nela à cet endroit.
Et effectivement, on s'en rend compte dans la vidéo qu'elle publie juste après :
*Bruit d'alarme*
Est-ce que c'est la sirène qui marque la fin de toute l'énigme ?
Est-ce qu'on a enfin la clef qui va éliminer le mystère ?
On en peut plus, nous !
Nela, en manque de réseau, va nous donner des nouvelles comme elle peut,
elle va nous dire qu'elle a fuit l'immeuble, qu'elle est juste à côté,
que l'alarme continue de sonner,
mais que des fois elle s'arrête pendant quelques secondes,
et que pendant ces quelques secondes, elle récupère du réseau.
Et à ce moment-là uniquement elle peut nous prévenir de ce qu'il s'est passé.
Elle tombe sur une sorte de grosse base où y'a des antennes,
comme une sorte de gros complexe télécom' un peu bizarre.
Du coup elle va appeler, au moment où y'a du réseau, le putain de numéro.
Alors qu'elle devrait appeler la police, totalement, je sais, on est d'accord !
Et le numéro lui dit :
*Voix grave et robotique qui parle espagnol*
Elle va alors comprendre que ce qu'ils attendent d'elle, c'est que...
elle rétablisse le signal.
Ce qu'elle nous avait pas dit, c'tte p'tite maligne,
ce qu'c'est une programmeuse,
donc du coup, elle s'y connaît bien en informatique.
Et elle va donc retourner dans l'immeuble au PC
pour essayer de rétablir son putain de signal
et qu'on ait enfin des réponses !
Une fois devant le PC, elle résout le problème,
et là...
on a plus de nouvelles de Nela pendant quelques temps.
Mais quand elle en redonne...
on comprend !
Après avoir réussi à réparer le signal,
les lumières se sont allumées,
l'alarme s'est arrêtée,
la couverture réseau a été complètement rétablie,
donc Nela a compris que le jeu était terminé.
Elle a aussi compris qu'elle a été choisie parce que c'était une candidate parfaite
et ils le savaient parce qu'elle avait partagé toutes les infos pour qu'ils le sachent sur ses réseaux sociaux,
comme tout le monde le fait.
Elle comprend aussi que c'est pas la seule à avoir vécu ce truc-là,
y'a d'autres candidats aussi qui ont fait toutes ces épreuves.
C'étaient des tests,
visant à recruter des gens dans l’organisation "Red Monkey",
le singe rouge, là.
En gros, c'est...
carrément une secte,
qui travaille pour essayer de rendre internet plus sain,
pour que les gens soient moins en danger,
fassent plus gaffe à leurs données,
que leurs données soient en sécurité, etc.
Et leur manière de recruter étrange
met en évidence le fait qu'on partage tous beaucoup trop d'infos à nous sur internet
et qu'il est très facile de savoir
quasiment TOUT sur quelqu'un,
grâce à internet.
Par exemple, ils savaient que Nela elle adorait les énigmes et le mystère,
ils savaient que sa mère elle était très importante pour elle...
Bon ça faut pas être un génie, hein...!
Pfff ! A priori...
Ils savaient qu'elle réagirait comme ça,
quelles compétences elle avait, donc qu'elle était forte en développement,
qu'elle partagerait tout sur Twitter et que tout le monde l'aiderait et relayerait ça...
C'était pour eux une manière de savoir si elle était qualifiée et qu'elle pouvait rejoindre
la secte, hein, carrément,
et participer aux centaines de milliers d'attaques virtuelles qu'ils vont faire sur tous les serveurs,
sur lesquels sont hébergés les données de tous les humains.
Et bah putain, si on avait su ça...
*BIP* Les amis, c'est la fin du thread "Red Monkey" !
J'espère que ça vous a plu, n'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si c'est le cas !
Franchement il est trop bien foutu, y'a pleins de photos, pleins de vidéos...
Y'a quand même une p'tite morale cool,
c'est qu'effectivement faut faire attention à nos données, faut faire attention à c'qu'on partage sur les réseaux sociaux...
En fait, faut faire gaffe à c'que les gens peuvent savoir de nous,
alors qu'ils nous connaissent même pas dans la vraie vie et que nous on les connaît pas.
Et ça c'est vrai, et on a tous tendance à partager beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de notre vie privée
sur internet, globalement,
et c'est... ça peut être TRÈS dangereux.
Je le rappelle si y'en a qu'on pas compris, tout ça c'est fictif.
C'est une fiction qu'a été écrite par Nela
avec aussi quelqu'un d'autre, qu'on connaît bien...
*accent espagnol* MANUAL BARTUAAAAL
Qui a écrit le thread,
vous vous souvenez !
C'est lui ! C'est lui qu'avait écrit ce thread !
Et il en a même fait un livre, derrière !
Manual ! *Bruit de bisou* Bravo, c'est génial !
J'espère que ça vous a plu,
et puis... voilà...
j'vous dis à bientôt
sur YouTube dans une autre vidéo ou sur Twitch en live,
chaque jeudi de 20h à minuit.
Voilààà, c'est lancé, l'info.
A bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo, au revoir !
♫ Hit+Run - "À l'affût" ♫